>> Martha: TONIGHT CHINA IS
PUSHING BACK AGAINST A GROWING
U.S. INTELLIGENCE THAT POINTS TO
WUHAN AND A MISTAKE IN THE LAB
THERE THAT WAS STUDYING THE
VIRUS IN BATS.
THAT MAY HAVE LED TO THIS GLOBAL
PANDEMIC.
THE FOCUS IS ON AN INFECTED
WORKER WHO SPREAD IT TO HER
PARTNER.
SHE MAY BE THE PATIENT ZERO
TREND OF THE WORLD HAS BEEN
LOOKING FORWARD ACCORDING TO
THIS LATEST INTELLIGENCE REPORT.
JOINING ME NOW, REPUBLICAN
SENATOR MARCO RUBIO OF FLORIDA,
SENATOR, ALWAYS GOOD TO SEE YOU.
HOW MUCH CREDIBILITY DO YOU GIVE
THIS EMERGING STORY?
>> I THINK IT’S ONE WORTH PAYING
ATTENTION TO.
IT WOULD BE A DRAMATIC, EARTH
SHATTERING REVELATION IF IT
TURNS OUT TO BE THE CASE AND
THAT WOULD BE THE CASE FOR TWO
REASONS, ONE THING, SOMEONE
BECAME INFECTED IN THE LAB AND
THEY INFECTED OTHER PEOPLE,
THAT’S CONCERNING.
THE SAFETY STANDARDS THERE ARE
NOT HIGH.
ANOTHER THING COMPLETELY IS THAT
OUR GOVERNMENT, WHEN THEY
LEARNED OF IT, WHAT ACTUALLY
ACTIVELY ATTEMPT TO COVER IT UP.
FROM THE BEGINNING OF THE
CRISIS, THE CHINESE HAVE BEEN
LESS THAN TRANSPARENT.
IF SOMETHING HAPPENED LIKE THAT
IN THE UNITED STATES, THERE
WOULD BE, BECAUSE WE ARE AN OPEN
SOCIETY AND DEMOCRACY, THERE
WOULD BE ALMOST IMMEDIATE
ACCOUNTABILITY AND REVELATION
ABOUT IT AT SOME POINT.
THERE WOULD BE A BIG PRICE TO
PAY FOR COVERING THAT UP LEGALLY
AND POLITICALLY.
IT COULD BE A TREMENDOUS GLOBAL
SCANDAL, ONE OF THE MOST
OUTRAGEOUS THINGS TO HAPPEN IF
THAT WERE TO TURN OUT TO BE
TRUE.
>> Martha: WHAT’S THE NEXT
STEP?
I THINK WE TALK SO MUCH ABOUT
HOLDING CHINA ACCOUNTABLE.
THE PRESIDENT WAS PRETTY
FORCEFUL ON THIS IN A VERY SORT
OF SUBTLE WAY, IF YOU CAN DO
BOTH OF THOSE THINGS AT ONCE.
HE SAID PEOPLE SHOULD HAVE TOLD
US.
PEOPLE SHOULD HAVE TOLD US.
HE SAID THAT SEVERAL TIMES.
THAT’S A PRETTY, I THINK PRETTY
CLEAR MESSAGE THAT HE IS NOT
LIKING WHAT HE’S HEARING ABOUT
THIS.
>> IT’S REMINISCENT SOMEWHAT OF
CHERNOBYL WHICH WAS OBVIOUSLY,
THAT ACCIDENT A WHILE BACK AND
IRONICALLY THERE WAS THE SERIES
RECENTLY ABOUT IT AND THE WAY
THE SOVIET GOVERNMENT REACTED TO
IT.
IF THIS TURNS OUT TO BE THE
CASE, IT’S VERY REMINISCENT OF
THAT.
YOU’RE ALREADY SEEING SOME
PEOPLE IN AFRICA AND POOR
COUNTRY SAYING CHINA SHOULD BE
CONTRIBUTING TO SOME SORT OF
GLOBAL FUND TO HELP PAY
REPARATIONS FOR WHAT THEY’VE
GONE THROUGH.
I THINK THERE WILL BE SOME TOUGH
CONVERSATIONS THROUGHOUT THE
WORLD ABOUT WHAT NEEDS TO BE
DONE ABOUT THIS.
AT THIS POINT NO MATTER WHAT YOU
MAY BE READING, SOME ARTICLES
OUT THERE BY SOME PEOPLE WHO
THINK THEY KNOW IT ALL, HERE’S
THE TRUTH.
CHINA’S REPUTATION GLOBALLY HAS
ALREADY BEEN BADLY DAMAGED.
PLENTY OF COUNTRIES OUT THERE
KNOW EXACTLY HOW CHINA
MISHANDLED THIS.
IRRESPECTIVE OF WHETHER IT CAME
OUT OF THE LAB OR NOT, THEY ARE
NOT TALKING ABOUT IT BECAUSE
THEIR ECONOMIES ARE NOT BIG
ENOUGH TO TAKE CHINA ON
DIRECTLY.
BUT THE DAMAGE THAT CHINA HAS
SUFFERED TO ITS PERCEPTION
AROUND THE WORLD IS IN MANY WAYS
IRREPARABLE.
>> Martha: I GUESS THE
QUESTION BECOMES, WE HEAR A LOT
ABOUT RAGE.
WE HEAR PEOPLE SAY THEY DON’T
LIKE THE FACT THAT ALL OF OUR
ANTIBIOTICS, MOST OF THEM ARE
MADE IN CHINA.
I KNOW YOU’VE WORKED ON THIS, TO
BRING BACK THE PRODUCTION OF
THESE DRUGS AT HOME.
I THINK THE AMERICAN PEOPLE KIND
OF WANT TO KNOW WHEN THEY’RE
GOING TO SEE ALL OF THAT ACTUAL
HAPPEN.
WE HEAR THE PRESIDENT TALK ABOUT
THE TRADE DEAL ON HOW IMPORTANT
THAN TRADE DEAL IS AND HOW HE
WANTS TO KEEP IT GOING.
HOW CAN WE HAVE A RELATIONSHIP
WITH THIS COUNTRY IF THIS THIS I
TRUE?
>> YEAH.
OVER A YEAR AGO I RELEASED THE
REPORT CALLED MADE IN CHINA
2025, PLAN TO REINVIGORATE
AMERICA’S INDUSTRY.
THE BASIC PREMISE WAS THERE ARE
SOME THINGS THAT EVEN IF THEY
ARE CHEAPER TO MAKE SOMEWHERE
ELSE, WE HAVE TO BE ABLE TO MAKE
IN OUR OWN COUNTRY FOR OUR OWN
SECURITY.
THANK GOD FOR THE AMERICAN
FARMER.
THANK GOD WE DIDN’T OUTSOURCE
THAT.
I THINK YOU ARE SEEING SOME OF
THOSE THINGS EXPOSED NOW FROM
NASAL SWABS THAT WE NEED FOR
THAT TEST TO PERSONAL PROTECTIVE
EQUIPMENT, THE COMPONENTS THAT
GO INTO A VENTILATOR.
THEY DO KEEP GOING ALL THE WAY
TO RARE EARTH MINERALS WHICH ARE
CRITICAL FOR ALMOST ALL OF
HIGH TECH.
THE WORLD IS OVERLY DEPENDENT ON
CHINA AND OUR SUPPLY CHAIN.
YES, IT’S CHEAPER TO DO THOSE
THINGS OVER THERE BUT WE CANNOT
AFFORD FROM AN ECONOMIC AND
NATIONAL SECURITY STANDPOINT TO
NOT HAVE THE INDUSTRIAL CAPACITY
TO DO THINGS, NOT TO MENTION THE
JOBS THAT COME WITH IT.
IT’S SOMETHING WE SHOULD’VE BEEN
LOOKING ON ALREADY.
I THINK THIS CRISIS WILL ONLY
ACCELERATE IT.
>> Martha: I THINK YOU’VE GOT
A LOT OF AGREEMENT ON THAT.
IF IT TURNS OUT THAT THEY SAT ON
THIS FOR SIX DAYS AND DIDN’T
TELL ANYONE, HELD A HUGE
INTERNATIONAL FESTIVAL KNOWING
THIS IN WUHAN AND THEN LET
PEOPLE FLY ALL OVER THE WORLD
AFTERWARDS, THAT, AS YOU SAY, IS
GOING TO BE AN INTERNATIONAL
SCANDAL OF EPIC PROPORTION WHEN
YOU LOOK AT WHAT’S HAPPENED TO
SO MANY PEOPLE AROUND THIS WORLD
AND STILL HAPPENING IN SOME OF
THE DEVELOPING NATIONS IN A WAY
THAT’S GOING TO BE VERY, VERY